the kid has been avoiding me for three  years and even his own fans now are just  like dude stop talking about it because  he clearly doesn't want to do it really  i said i'll fight you in london you  could be the a side i don't give a [ __ ]  i just want to knock you the hell out  and he just won't do it and then is  tweeting me for the past two years all  the time clickbaiting me on youtube damn  near his whole entire social media  strategy is just to talk about me so he  doesn't even get to the terms no it  doesn't like what are the excuses what's  the kind of [ __ ] he'll say like oh well  i can't do it because this i'm doing my  music tour and  i'm busy like bro you're selling out 800  person rooms like no one gives a [ __ ]  about your music  little bank and now all the influencers  are trying to box because they see jake  paul made 45 million dollars last year  is that how much you mean yeah and ksi  and cassie